dans un premier temps monsieur le
ministre je vais vous dire moi je suis
un policier de base je n'ai pas demandé
à syndical donc je suis dans
l'obligation de vous demander
l'autorisation de pouvoir m'exprimer
évidemment sans avoir de sanction
derrière promis je vous remercie ouais
vérifiera parce que c'est bon mon
directeur vous remercie voilà monsieur
le ministre
vous avez des policiers qui adorent leur
métier on est là pour protéger la
population
tous les jours on est confronté à des
choses dramatiques
on est confronté à des situations
difficiles délicates
qui nous oblige effectivement à prendre
des décisions à faire des choses
et aujourd'hui en fait monsieur le
ministre votre police alors on peut plus
elle craque
votre police n'est je suis très très
émue chez mes collègues qui travaillent
ce soir j'ai embrassent qui fasse
attention à eux
votre police elle craque votre police
elle en peut plus parce que on est
détesté bon ça on a l'habitude
on nous insulte ça à la limite on a
l'habitude
on nous tue
et moi je suis maire de famille comme
beaucoup de mes collègues j'ai pas envie
de crever très clairement
moi des refus d'obtempérer monsieur j'en
ai fait plusieurs
avec mes collègues
pourquoi les gens ne s'arrêtent pas
c'est dramatique pour votre fille je ne
connais pas la situation il était arrêté
donc je me permettrais pas de juger mais
je vous dis que moi personnellement j'ai
j'ai fait des refus d'obtempérer
il y a pas très longtemps j'ai été
victime également d'un monsieur multi
récidiviste qu'on appelle par son prénom
maintenant qui m'a mordu voilà parce
qu'il avait envie de me mordre
au bout d'un moment monsieur le ministre
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
la justice nous laisse tomber
sauf pour nous sanctionner parce que là
on est bien d'accord que on est
sanctionné monsieur sachez-le on est
sanctionné beaucoup plus que vous vous
le seriez pour les mêmes faits
la justice je peux pas laisser dire ça
mais parce que moi si je mens devant un
procure un policier je suis déféré
est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec moi
est-ce que vous pouvez confirmer le fait
qu'un policier qui ment devant
l'IGPN n'a aucune sanction
administrative totalement faux monsieur
je ne peux pas porter plainte contre lui
pourquoi je ne peux pas porter plainte
contre lui une fois je me permettrais
pas de parler de votre de votre dossier
monsieur parce que je ne connais pas
donc je me permets de parler
on comprend la colère et les mois de
dissam mais juste quand je pense que
quand vanessaie de parler de de
sanctions elle parlait de de sanctions
monsieur vous n'imaginez pas à quel
point alors vous allez être contrôlé en
état des briété sur la voie publique que
vous allez avoir une sanction moi je
vais je vais être contrôlé je vais avoir
le double de la sanction plus une
sanction administrative
si si Monsieur demandez à notre ministre
voilà ce qui est vrai c'est que les
policiers sont les fonctionnaires non
seulement les plus contrôlés mais qui
connaissent le plus de sanctions de tous
les fonctionnaires moi je peux dire par
exemple à Madame que si elle devait
conduire en état débriété et qu'elle
devait faire une tentative domicile sous
le coudre ce serait plus policière je la
suspendrais évidemment les policiers on
en parlera peut-être tout à l'heure sur
conjugales désormais et policiers les
gendarmes qui sont convaincus de de
violence conjugales des façons
définitive et qu'on a de la prison avec
sursis ou prise en ferme ne sont plus
policiers et gendarmes ne les excluons
voilà alors évidemment il y a encore
beaucoup de choses à faire je pense
madame en revanche excusez moi et vous
avez tout à fait raison sur la colère de
la police on va revenir à votre question
mais que c'est normal par ailleurs c'est
à dire que je trouve normal que parce
qu'on est policier qu'on a une arme
qu'on représente l'autorité quand on
fait des choses qu'on reproche aux
autres
c'est assez logique qu'on puisse vous
sanctionner ah oui tout à fait non mais
non mais je suis pas contre la sanction
mais on le dit mais vous avez raison de
le dire moi je vais vous dire quelque
chose chez nous il y a des pourris il y
a des pourris comme partout
chez nous
il y en a beaucoup
partout en politique absolument pas
là je réponds pas ça
on n'en peut plus moi j'ai des millions
d'exemples à vous raconter
alors je ne suis pas là pour taper sur
la justice que les choses soient très
claires je sais que la justice manque de
moyens je vais vous officier de police
judiciaire un jour j'étais de permanence
et j'ai un collègue qui vient me voir il
me dit on était on a fait un outrage
rébellion etc ah ouais là ça fait 10
fois qu'on l'interpelle je veux déposer
plainte je lui dis ok d'accord pas de
souci je fais la procédure j'appelle le
magistrat pour lui rendre compte et là
le magistrat vous savez ce qu'il me dit
mais dites-moi j'espère que c'est pas
Monsieur Untel parce que quand même
c'est souvent qui dépose plainte comment
Monsieur moi en tant que fonctionnaire
de police je peux accepter ça comment
tous les jours on pourrait tous les
jours on pourrait déposer plaintes dix
fois par jour tous les jours on ne le
fait pas pourquoi parce que la procédure
c'est long c'est compliqué c'est voilà
on ne fait pas mais tous les jours on
pourrait le faire et la réponse elle est
où en ce qui nous concerne elle est où
la réponse pénale par contre j'ai des
collègues qui effectivement au début du
covid ont donné un coup de poing à un
gars qui leur a craché dessus
en disant j'ai le covid tu vas crever
avec des jolis noms d'oiseaux mes
collègues ils sont tellement ils sont
passés au tribunal le misent en cause
était en visio parce qu'il était
incarcéré dans une autre prison il
insultait mes collègues qui étaient à la
barre et la présidente n'a rien dit
il est traité excusez-moi monsieur le
ministre de fils de [ __ ] et la
présidente n'a rien dit
comment on peut laisser faire ça on est
qui on est on est plus rien en fait on
est plus personne comment voulez-vous
messieurs dames comment voulez-vous
qu'on vous protège si on nous protège
pas à nous aussi au bout d'un moment
monsieur le ministre on va péter un
plomb
alors Vanessa vous avez résumé
vraiment ce que ce qui est énormément de
gens pensent sur les sur les réseaux
sociaux je sais que Monsieur Darmanin et
Monsieur le Ministre essayer de protéger
sa police le mieux possible mais c'est
vrai que on vous en parlait tout à
l'heure on le voit et j'ai de nombreux
témoignages comme celui de Vanessa les
policiers n'en peuvent plus avant que
vous répondiez Gérald Darmanin
j'aimerais juste qu'on entende juste
aussi Perrine qui est dans le public
parce que elle est fan de la policier de
la BAC et elle aussi elle n'en peut plus
les menacée de mort régulièrement car
fan de flic elle est la Perrine juste
sans poser même de questions juste
raconter votre quotidien à Monsieur le
Ministre parce que c'est vraiment on a
pris deux personnes qui représentent ce
qui se passe actuellement une femme d'un
policier et et Vanessa qui représente et
qui est la parole de Vanessa elle est
partagée par énormément de policiers qui
doivent nous regarder ce soir oui
bonsoir Monsieur le Ministre bonsoir à
tous merci Cyril de nous donner la
parole parce qu'effectivement moi je
suis compagne de policiers j'ai mon
compagnon qui part tous les soirs
travailler puisqu'il est fonctionnaires
de police de nuit il fait face à une
énorme délinquance il fait face à
effectivement des refus d'obtempérer du
trafic de stupéfiant mais également à
l'exhibition d'harmelongue le fait
d'intervenir régulièrement pour des
faits de violence conjugales et essayer
de faire au mieux son travail tous les
soirs c'est une angoisse tous les soirs
on se demande si l'être cher va rentrer
tous les soirs
on s'inquiète mais plus encore
maintenant on s'inquiète pas seulement
pour nos hommes et nos femmes qui vous
protègent mais on s'inquiète également
pour nos vies pour notre sécurité alors
moi je vais effectivement vous parler de
ce quotidien là effectivement je suis
menace et de mort personnellement la
présidente de l'association femme des
forces de l'ordre en colère Aurélie
Laroussi et menacé de mort sa fille est
menacée de viol voire même d'avoir ses
yeux arrachés pour le simple fait qu'on
est femme de flic
qu'on est enfant de flic
j'ai eu l'immense honneur d'avoir été
reçu également par Marianne Schiappa
effectivement pendant cette entretien là
on a pu évoquer différents éléments de
notre quotidien ces éléments là que
malheureusement beaucoup me connaissent
et aujourd'hui
il y a une profonde angoisse et une
profonde peur c'est pas rien de se
présenter en tant que femme de flic sur
un plateau télé un visage découvert avec
mon vrai nom mon vrai prénom pour vous
parler de ce quotidien là parce
qu'aujourd'hui si je suis présente on
parlait tout à l'heure de nos parents ma
mère là elle est en train de faire un
nul c'est représentant parce qu'elle a
peur que je ne que je ne survive pas aux
menaces qui nous sont données donc
effectivement je vous parle de ce
quotidien là de ce quotidien qui est
fort qui est poignant ce quotidien ou
juste parce qu'on est parent de flics
femme de flics enfant de flic on est
menacé alors nous aujourd'hui dans
l'association on a une revendication
vous me direz après ce que vous en
pensez
c'est la reconnaissance d'une forme de
discrimination
aujourd'hui si je suis menacé de mort
c'est pas parce que je m'appelle Perrine
c'est parce que je suis fan de flic
si aujourd'hui on a des membres dans
l'association qui se font refuser des
logements de vacances pour aller voir
leur enfant policier et qu'ils ont le
malheur de l'évoquer c'est parce que ils
sont parents de flics si aujourd'hui on
a des gamins dans des cours de récré qui
se font harceler frappés qui font qui
génère désormais des faux biscolaires
parce que ils sont enfants de flics
c'est parce que bien sûr ils sont
enfants de flic alors ce quotidien là
monsieur le ministre je me permets de
vous le remettre parce qu'effectivement
avec la présidente de l'association
femme défense de l'ordre en colère nous
avons écrit un livre ce livre il
s'appelle puta flic
pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui ce sont
ces menaces-là ces insultes là qu'on
reçoit au quotidien donc je me
permettrai de vous le remettre si vous
voulez bien merci
merci voilà merci à vous
et je me permets qu'avec je me permets
qu'avec la lecture de ce livre vous
découvrirez ce que c'est que ce
quotidien
de femmes de flic que c'est ce qu'est ce
quotidien d'avoir peur d'avoir un parent
flic pour vous donner une anecdote il y
a un policier qui a été tué récemment
ce policier là il y avait pas eu
d'hommage qui lui avait Torr rendu à
Paris avec notre association à net
décidé de lui rendre hommage parce que
lui aussi il était père d'une petite
fille parce que ça son épouse nous avait
contacté également
on a décidé de lui rendre hommage la
préfecture de police avait bouclé tout
Paris il fallait surtout pas qu'on
rentre en hommage en période de covid
effectivement couvre-feu obligeait mais
comme Christophe Castaner l'avait déjà
évoqué l'émotion peut dépasser la règle
donc on a décidé de se rassembler et à
ce moment là il y a eu un commissaire
qui était présent qui est venu nous
parler un petit peu nous avons remercié
de cet événement là et nous avoir dit
vous savez ma fille elle a 16 ans elle
vient à peine de découvrir que je suis
flic la plus de 20 ans de bouteilles
qu'est-ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui pour
protéger nos familles et pour protéger
nos jeunes et que pensez-vous cette
reconnaissance du fait de la
discrimination du fait de la profession
merci Perrine merci
à vous et on a entendu de SOS
SOS de Vanessa SOS de Perrine
monsieur ministre je sais que ça vous
fait mal d'entendre ça
c'est mal à tous les Français mais
surtout à vous parce que tous les
Français parce que Madame si vous me
permettait vous avez dit votre police je
comprends pourquoi vous le faites dans
le débat mais c'est la police de la
République c'est la police de tout le
monde d'ailleurs j'ai l'habitude de dire
un débat que j'ai parfois avec Monsieur
Mélenchon ou c'est représentant c'est
que les gens qui choisissent la police
nationale les gardiens de la paix comme
vous pardon de le dire comme ça mais
c'est rarement les enfants des grands
patrons c'est les enfants du peuple les
enfants ne fonctionnaires d'employés de
commerçants les gamins de 19 20 30 ans
les gamins et les gamines pardon de le
dire comme ça qui que je vois dans les
écoles de police c'est des jeunes quand
on dit les jeunes de la police mais il y
a plein de jeunes qui vont dans la
police Saint-Germain d'abord c'est notre
police collective
ce qui veut pas dire qu'elle a pas des
excès qu'elle a pas des difficultés mais
c'est notre police elle nous protège
toutes et tous et puis je pense que ce
que vous deux témoignages mesdames
plus que je ne peux le faire parce que
vous vivez
par votre choix par le choix de votre
conjoint ce métier cette vocation parce
que par ailleurs vos maris ils aiment
sans doute leur métier aussi et votre
même vous êtes sans doute très passionné
malgré tout encore par votre métier ou
en tout cas vous l'avez été d'ailleurs à
ce propos je vous invite si vous le
souhaitez vous vous grimez mais non mais
tonton
parce que sinon les gens vont se douter
pendant les quelques semaines qui
viennent deuxièmement moi je fais des
visites de commissariat de brigade de
gendarmerie vous le savez bien ça se dit
dans la police sans prévenir personne
sans patron sans préfet de police ce
matin je suis allé ce matin je suis allé
Aubervilliers 100 personnes j'ai été
chercher le préfet de police je lui dis
tu es où parce que je le tutoie il m'a
dit chez mon bureau je suis en bas de
chez toi il est bon pour quoi faire j'y
viens et j'ai juste dit à mon chauffeur
où est-ce qu'on allait au commissade de
bervilliers et personne n'était prévenu
et je le fais la nuit le jour parce que
j'essaie de comprendre en dehors de la
hiérarchie en dehors de ce qu'évidemment
au cash parfois au ministre de
l'Intérieur je suis pas totalement mais
je vais vous dire Madame que beaucoup de
gens aussi qui aiment leur métier donc
vous pouvez essayer de de résoudre ce
problème parce que
d'abord les gens ne vous détestent pas
je vous laisserai pas le dire
l'immense majorité des Français de leur
policiers il y a une minorité
d'emmerdeurs qui n'aime pas les
policiers mais quelque part c'est un peu
rassurant mais je savais très bien que
les gens ne vous détestent pas il y
avait des choses c'est qu'on peut pas
laisser dire n'importe quoi sur les
policiers donc ça c'est mon travail
aussi et je pense que je le fais voilà
et je pense que j'essaye de quoi qu'il
arrive descendre l'honneur des policiers
des policiers de davantage vous protéger
alors il y a beaucoup de questions qui
touche le garder ça faut éviter ça
examen parce que vous avez raison parce
que ce qu'elle est en train de dire
Vanessa aussi ils se font insulter
grand public maintenant c'est pas vrai
qui aime les policiers qui fait un
travail formidable maintenant elle est
remplacé avec Sonia baquet qui est à
côté mais je regrette de pas voir les
deux si j'ose dire auprès de moi là
vraiment Marlène elle a fait un travail
formidable et ça m'étonne pas qu'elle
vous ait reçu parce que voilà elle a un
cœur et une écoute mais au moment il y a
un policier qui m'a dit je peux vous
parler à côté donc je suis sur le côté
il était pas syndicaliste il m'a dit
monsieur le ministre je mets pas sur le
carnet de bord de mes enfants le métier
ce que je fais
on est on est une majorité quoi qu'on
pense les gens on est une majorité à
faire notre travail comme il faut une
immense majorité dans le respect dans le
respect de tout un chacun
mais quand il y a eu le covid par
exemple que on contrôle les gens et
qu'un monsieur très bien somme toute
très bien qui me dit ta cattle [ __ ] au
cul ton certificat
au bout d'un moment
c'est pas que des délinquants je veux
dire ce ne sont pas que des délinquants
qui qui ont ce genre de comportement ça
peut être n'importe qui c'est pas pour
non mais c'est pas pour excuser
évidemment ces comportement mais tous
les maires de France pourrez-vous la
même chose c'est que désormais les
concitoyens quel que soit leur niveau
social
ne respecte de moins en moins on l'a dit
pour d'autres choses plus violentes
l'autorité je vais dire à Madame que
tout à l'heure a dit quelque chose de
très de très important
je trouve moi qui est de dire voilà on
est on n'est pas toujours entendu je
pense que pendant longtemps les
ministres de l'intérieur ou la
hiérarchie
n'écoutez pas assez la base et c'est pas
démagogique le dire parce que le
problème de la police nationale si je
peux me permettre c'est que il y a des
commissaires il y a des officiers
formidables qui font des choses la nuit
qui sont présents et puis il y a aussi
des gens qui vivent pas la même chose
que les policiers de base vous savez moi
la première chose que je fais quand je
rentre dans un commissariat sans
prévenir personne c'est je demande où
sont les vestiaires puis après je vois
où sont les douches et quand le
commissaire de police officier ne sait
pas où sont les vestiaires les douches
c'est qu'il y a un problème c'est qu'il
doit pas prendre souvent sa douche et
ses vestiaires avec ses collègues voyez
l'immense majorité des commissaires ils
connaissent emboutiques ils sont près de
leurs hommes il y a des gens voyez qui
sont peut-être pas assez auprès des
hommes et parfois dans les bêtises ou
les erreurs que font un certain nombre
de policiers parce qu'ils sont aussi
très jeunes on les met aussi très jeune
dans l'hyper violence faut aussi avouer
ça je dis à Monsieur là c'est bien une
chose qu'on peut changer c'est
qu'aujourd'hui vous savez la système de
la police et je suis en train de le
changer c'est des gens pas assez formés
peut-être on passe maintenant de 12 mois
la formation avant c'était 8 mois c'est
aussi des gens monsieur qu'on parle des
stands de tir près de chez eux il y a
des gens qui font 50 60 km pour ces suit
au tir ça c'est responsabilité de l'État
pour répondre à ce que disait mettre
tout à l'heure c'est aussi et je pense
que ça pourrait extrêmement important
des gens qui a jusqu'à présent pas
énormément de matériel moi j'ai changé
deux tiers de votre parc automobile je
me rappelle des nuits que je passais
avec la BAC à Tourcoing ils avaient ils
avaient les barres de fer qui est
rentrés dans leur dos bon donc c'est des
petites choses de changer par automobile
mais je pense au moins c'est qu'elles
vont pas très très vite quand même pour
les refus d'obtempérer c'est pour ça
qu'on a acheté des alpines pour les
grands refus d'obtempérer mais je peux
pas acheter voiture de course pour tout
le monde parce qu'au moment des impôts
des gens donc je veux dire à Monsieur
que ce que nous faisons aussi parce que
le policier qui a tiré vous voyez
monsieur pour lui aussi j'imagine je le
connais pas c'est un drame d'abord tu es
un homme malgré tout j'ai juste envie de
me surpris je vous laisserai évidemment
répondre mais quand on prend des
policiers de 18 19 20 ans pour les sorts
de parfois de leur campagne et qu'on les
plonge à Paris puisque j'ai compris que
vous étiez la Préfecture de Police de de
Paris en tout cas pour Madame si j'ai
bien compris bon ben pour Monsieur non
non moi je suis un commissariat de
province petit dans une petite ville
mais quand on les plonge à Paris par
exemple qui est un
Hauts-de-Seine Val-de-Marne on les
oblige à aller quand ils ont 18 19 20
ans pendant 8 ans 9 ans à Paris donc on
les on les prend de leur campagne si
j'ose dire et on les met dans l'hyper
violence à 19 20 ans quand on n'est pas
toujours construit quand on a sa
conjoint ou son conjointe qu'il a pas un
peu suivi parfois on a des enfants et je
pense que c'est pas un bon modèle aussi
pour nous c'est pas on remplace service
ça c'est policier dans l'affaire dans la
faire éclairs par exemple on va rappeler
pour les téléspectateurs la force
éclairs c'est ce producteur de musique
qui rentrait dans son studio de musique
qui a été qui nous avait raconté qu'il
avait été frappé sans raison par trois
policiers et qui avait tenté de rentrer
dans son studio de la musique c'est ça
il y a deux choses extrêmement
choquantes il y a ce qui s'est passé
pour Monsieur zeclerc bien évidemment
mais aussi le fait moi j'ai regardé
quand vous dites qu'est-ce que vous
faites quand vous voyez ça j'ai regardé
des images les images c'est il y avait
une quinzaine de policiers dans cette
rue dans le 17e arrondissement à 19h il
n'était pas si tard que ça
et quand j'ai demandé est-ce qu'il y
avait un officier avec eux et pas
d'officier avec eux et là il y a un
problème de l'État d'organisation ça
c'est mon problème c'est que qu'on peut
pas envoyer 15 policiers dans un endroit
quand il y a des appels et pas avoir un
chef moi je vous dis aussi que les gens
vont vous répondre c'est mon travail
mais bien sûr mais c'est mon travail
tous les jours vous savez tous les jours
faut remettre à l'ouvrage il y a 250000
policiers gendarmes c'est pas facile à
organiser donc je dis pas que chauffe
pas d'excuses c'est mon boulot mon
boulot c'est que vous deux si vous me
permettez cette expression vous puissiez
vous parler ce que vous madame vous vous
êtes perdu votre fils bon quel que soit
ce que dira l'enquête judiciaire il y a
pas il y a pas de mots monsieur et vous
madame vous me dites ce que ce qui me
touche beaucoup également c'est que vous
n'en pouvez plus faire mesdames de votre
métier le métier de votre mari et le
travail de du ministre de l'intérieur
c'est de vous donner le meilleur
matériel les meilleurs moyens les
meilleurs cadres légal le meilleur
défense moral aussi la meilleure
formation pour que jamais madame vous
puissiez continuer à dire quelque chose
comme ça vous le dites c'est qu'on n'a
pas été extrêmement bon voilà